[Music]
[Laughter]
it's something they do with gardening
this garden in the world has nothing to
do with gardening yeah it has no it
doesn't it nope what is it there it is
[Applause]
yeah pretty close it is i believe the
longest running radio play
ever the archers that's what it is from
radio 4 the actors from radio now you
probably noticed um there's someone else
in the studio who are right just done
just there
introduce because he's your friend and
very quickly becoming mine and he's he's
sitting where you normally sit yeah it's
mr james master
thank you for your seat this is a very
nice seat you're keeping it warm yeah i
really am thank you
thanks for coming in james that's very
kind of you yeah when i asked you i
thought yeah i thought you'd definitely
say no
i thought you'd say
i'm just a little busy for that man no
i've been looking for this all week
i'm just locked down in my house
so you know i get out you live in
california james yeah yeah now james
we'll give you a little official blurb
here because for anyone who uh wants to
know exactly
who mr james master is here we go james
wesley masters i'm gonna get into the
wesley thing in a second he's an actor
musician and comic book writer best
known for his roles in the british
vampire as the british oh in the british
as the british vampire
spike in the tv show buffy the vampire
slayer
and its spin-off angel since then he has
played the alien supervillain brainiac
on smallville with our friend michael
rosenbaum true captain john hart in
torchwood amazing show and terrorist
barnabas greeley
is that right
yes he's sci-fi's capricorn he also
plays in the band ghost of the robot
mission
and you go
and you guys know each other from a
certain convention or some convention
well
yeah we've just kind of met over the
years and conventions and
and just being in that little small town
called hollywood yeah that we keep
bumping into each other exactly so um
and i was a huge
i don't know if i've told you this
before but i was a huge buffy fan and
you have natto i also play in a band
called bee cake and i have your cd that
was awesome good i'm glad you enjoyed it
i enjoy your music as well thank you and
um
i know her uh guitarist billy johnson
loved buffy and i saw i i never thought
it would be my thing you know yeah and
he gave me the box set and i just
devoured it i loved it it was brilliant
and you were incredible in that show
absolutely incredible get ready for the
ultimate winter night in brought to you
by beam beam is a functional wellness
brand that makes products to help you
pursue your better and push the
boundaries of what's possible white
chocolate peppermint dream powder only
lasts for a limited time so get it while
it's hot great news if you subscribe now
you can take advantage of beam's best
sale of the year for black friday and
cyber monday you'll get 40
off the first three months of peppermint
dream subscription plus a free mug and
frother or 20 off a one-time purchase
again this is beam's biggest offer of
the year and just like this new flavor
it won't last long head to beam organics
dot com slash onion that's b e a m
organics dot com slash onion for forty
percent of the first three months of
peppermint dream subscription plus free
mug and frother or twenty percent off
one time purchase subscriptions are
month to month and can be paused or
cancelled at any time i'm like you i i
didn't think it would be my cup of tea
either like i came into los i came to
los angeles because i had i had a son
and i had to stop doing theater and come
down to television and i came down and i
told my agent
i do not care
about awards i don't care about quality
i'm here for money i need diaper money
doctor money and college money i'll be
the new urkel i will be lucky i don't
care she's like oh no
i love you
and uh they gave me the audition for for
for buffy and i was like oh no not that
that's horrible
because i saw the movie i didn't like
the movie right and they're like it's a
tv show it's different watch it and call
us back after the show and i watched 15
minutes in the first commercial break i
called my agent back i was like this
thing is incredible oh my god yeah it
was just really well written it just
worked so well did you watch it now i've
seen buffy the vampire slayer i don't
think i've watched all of the back to
back in box sets like you are but for
anyone who doesn't know it
buffy the vampire slayer follows buffy
who's going through college and then in
her very hot and then in her nights she
slays vampires is that the the general
yeah vibe of the show she tries to be
normal so normal stuff falling in love
maybe a problem at school problem with
just chef parents are they around she
has a mother mm-hmm she has a dad and
the various dad is yeah the dad is
wow okay so that probably adds a little
bit of extra kind of baggage to buffy
yeah and no one at the school knows that
she slays vampires is it a secret she
has a few friends who know her secret
okay and they yeah they help her slay
and or get in the way of her trying to
slay right to comedic or horrifying
effect and from my kind of recollection
in in the times where i've watched it
it's kind of
it's purposefully a little
kind of
outrageous like it's quite vampy is that
right i don't mean vampires in vampires
i mean it's quite
that is showy the trick
uh and why i didn't like the movie is
because the writing is very sparkly
but if you play it
then if you vamp it
uh if you play it arch as we like to say
it just
it's half as good as it should be and
the trick was to play it straight
to play it as if there's no comedy at
all and at that point it becomes
howlingly hilarious but you just have to
play it as if you're if you're doing
david mamet right and then suddenly
everyone thinks you're a funny person
but basically supposedly that's what how
leslie nielsen always approached his
roles in airplane and police squad he
played it as if it was completely
serious and everyone around him is
playing a joke and he's just like i'm a
detective and i'm trying to solve this
crime and it becomes incredibly funny
yeah yeah
and like all great kind of tv shows like
that it has it's through stories that
you but every week there'll be something
exciting or weird or a new villain comes
in or a new story that
that makes it interesting and brilliant
and i i wanted to ask you but i don't
think we get to it so early but
with your musical background the the
musical episode of buffy yeah i think is
the only time that i can think of where
an episodic has got that right
where it was just brilliant and i've
seen a lot of shows do you know where
they try to make a musical he had it
yeah that's just nuts e.r did it yeah er
it's brilliant yeah we were horrified
when we were asked to do it we really
thought this show was getting flushed
down the drain yeah jump in the shop
yeah like most of the most of the actors
very rightly
thought you know you hired me to be a
one-camera
dramatic slash comedic actor that's my
wheelhouse don't ask me to do something
i'm not good at yeah you're going to
ruin my career i think uh sarah who
played buffy has to juggle chainsaws she
said you know you can start him up i'll
juggle real chainsaws rather than have
to sing and be safer for my career wow
right um and they had a point actually
um but it was well received the moon is
collapsing yeah yeah i i
tony head and i we were comfortable
singing but i didn't think the songs
were very good
i really because joss gave gave us a
cassette tape of him singing this song
and as a singer he's a really good
writer
did he write the songs yeah yeah but he
was he was playing them on the piano i
just i don't know i'm a punk rocker and
i was just yeah this is terrible right
this is terrible and
we were all wrong you know what he's
doing and he does seem to know what he's
doing what do you think when you watch
it do you like that episode oh it's
fabulous i think it's brilliant
delightful yeah like that i think that's
a difficult thing to do to take out oh
and and make amusements so bizarre when
you first yeah i wonder what was the
first show that ever did that yeah
because there was an all musical cop
show that only ran for like half a
season do you remember that yes i don't
know i think it might be doing very well
no it might be called cop land or
something like that did terrible i know
er did it you said grey's anatomy did he
yeah
there's a couple more that i've missed
i think like
arrow or the flash they've done it they
definitely pitched it
very casually very casually to us when
we were doing last i remember it being
floated around
what about a musical version and
everyone was like absolutely not we're
not doing a musical version no one will
do it especially as you were the
musician and that show they'd wanted you
to really stand out i think i would have
been really you would have been pregnant
actually i think jorge garcia and i were
like how'd that be fun
but i think everyone else was kind of
like what that makes no sense and it
kind of doesn't make sense until
probably this buffy episode we go what
about that as an example that seems
silly but look it works you know that's
the one i always look back at and i
think that really worked whatever they
did how did that work why did it work
but for some reason it did
i didn't make it man i was just in it so
i can't even answer that question you
know
josh sweden yeah who i mean you must be
a massive joss whedon fan right because
he did
firefly and serenity yeah massive yeah i
really love that i love buffy i love it
he loves sci-fi like he's a
yeah big sci-fi yeah i love him
in fact talking about sci-fi you've got
a captain kirk white right now
oh do i really yeah
[Laughter]
i'm sure you don't mind me saying you
look fantastic
well i have the kirkland i can't yeah
he does if you have you seen that and
start uh star trek he has this weird
light
quite a lot yeah he's got just this
weird just strip of light along his eyes
where did that come from and just
imagine producing it and bill's asking
for that lighting and like i don't know
just give it to him we got to get this
thing well you've got it it looks great
yeah stick with it so now so how how
often are you at these conventions james
of an average year like pre-covert i
should say try to do no more than two a
month okay just because the travel gets
you know
it's a lot of energy they're high energy
events and i i'm actually i like to talk
with buffy fans because i'm
i'm a fan of buffy the show i'm a fan of
the writing which i didn't do so i'm not
bragging but but i i
buffy fans tend to say like oh you like
buffy let's talk like it's almost kind
of a hidden handshake oh that's cool and
so i fit in with the buffy fan so i
don't i i have a great time doing them
it's just the travel gets me and the the
different time zones and stuff so
where's the where's the furthest flong
you've gone on a convention australia oh
yeah so as far as you can go really yeah
and anytime i've seen you
at a convention
like if everyone's having dinner at
night or meeting for a drinksy i'm
meeting someone for a drink i never see
james and i i've always wondered where
does he go what does he do and i found
out okay
i found him yeah what do you do he's in
his room yeah
you'll like this yeah he travels with a
playstation is that right and he sits
and he plays games so much so that he
made a show out of it wow
called idiots yeah
oh was it there was a video shop in
santa monica called videos that's right
that it closed down by the time we
started so they couldn't sue us
years ago because billy's usually lived
on the west side while he's been in la
and back when we used to go to video
shops you used to call video it's and i
would go no it's vidios you're like no
no it's video it is why is it video is
it makes no sense makes me video it and
i called his show video as well whenever
i thought that was just your scottish
that was me
see it say it like i see it you know
what i mean videos that's what i kept
saying i was like
it's idiots videos
i don't get it i don't get it so what's
been your journey with with what we
would call computer games or video games
in your life and
how's that gone
i
i remember the first one i got i was
just so poor for so long that i didn't
really i couldn't afford video games but
i remember when
one of the mario games came out it was
64 or something and i this is in the 80s
in chicago and my my then wife and i uh
we gave each other
the the console and that one game yeah
and that's all we could afford and it
got us through a whole chicago winter it
was fabulous what was it what was the
game it was the mario super mario
brothers
before whatever whatever it was right
and um because that was the same console
that had the mario kart right the 64. i
guess but we couldn't we
we blew all the money on the one
cartridge in the one game but that's all
that we needed and um
and then that was it i didn't really
play video games again until i got down
here and started making money on
television
and then i guess it was the ps3 no i got
the ps2 yeah yeah uh and started playing
that with my son
and then that was just bit and i just
played everything and do you play
like just when you're traveling or will
you go home tonight and play something
i have enough time for about an hour a
day all right yeah and i always feel
like i deserve more but never don't we
all don't
hey fellas this episode of the
friendship onion is brought to you by
our favorite producers of tremors
manscapes the global leaders in below
the waste grooming are leaving 2021 with
a new product clean yourself into the
new year with their ultra premium body
wash also special offer alert use the
code onion for 20 off plus free shipping
at
manscape.com
four million men already trust manscaped
i think it's time to join them
i agree bills and also get this manscape
engineered the ultimate
groin and body trimmer by focusing on
intelligent functionality and an
incredibly comfortable grooming
experience their fourth generation
trimmer features a cutting-edge ceramic
blade to reduce grooming accidents
thanks to their advanced skin safe
technology and you can do it in the
shower because it's even waterproof i'll
tell you what tom 2021 sucked in many
ways and that's why manscaped is making
a splash and upping your grooming game
use the code onion for 20 off plus free
shipping at manscape.com i'm all in on
confidence and smelling good this year
join me with manskate get 20 off and
free shipping with the code onion at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com
and use code onion happy new year to
your balls
really what has it done well i'm from
manchester i know that and as you know
one of the things that a lot of
mancunian men take very seriously
alongside jackets and football is their
hair well that's true it's a big thing
isn't it liam gallagher the manchester
united manchester city footballers the
kind of vibe on the street everyone's
gotta have kind of a cool or whatever
they think is cool haircut i i've always
been a little self-conscious about a
receding hairline now there is a
solution out there i don't want to keep
your hair yeah and interestingly enough
it is
keeps keeps offers an easy access to
hair loss
they actually send prescription
medication directly to your door and if
you're a little you know kind of
self-conscious about getting something
about hair loss through the door don't
worry because everything's kind of
discreet and classy and uh it's a way to
keep all of your hair if you feel like
you want to do that which a lot of
people would like to do true because dom
two out of three men
will have some sort of hair loss by the
time they're 35 is that right that's
more than 50 million men in the u.s who
suffer from male pattern baldness
now dom there is only two
fda approved medications that can help
prevent hair loss how many do you think
keeps has tell me two both of them wow
keeps offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications as i said
delivered directly to your door every
three months you don't even need to
leave your home to keep your hair if you
are ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to k e e p s dot com slash
onion to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k e e p s dot
com slash onion to get your first month
free k e e p s dot com slash onion well
i'll tell you what me and dom love this
game called league of legends yeah and
we're always trying to get people on our
team because we're trying to go pro see
now this is the problem this is like
multiplayer so you play with human being
oh yeah no no you agree with us okay
you don't like playing with other humans
you like a self-contained you in the
comments i like to play against a
computer program that is very finely
tuned to let me win right you know yeah
i don't like to be beaten so you like to
win i do you might not like legal agents
i read
i read that when a male loses
his testosterone level
drops
so i just feel like on a health basis
it's better for me
well here's the thing with league of
legends it's important for you yes very
important exactly
so with league of legends not only
do you lose
which i lose all the time we all do
but because we don't it's a team of five
so sometimes it's just me and dom or me
dom and one other so there's two people
that we don't know are three people that
we don't know on our team yeah and they
will say things to me like
never play this game again
honestly they will rate that delete this
game
you are the worst player i've ever seen
and sometimes even worse stuff that i'm
not even gonna say because it's kind of
hateful and awful this is why
yeah this is cynical enough about human
beings if if i get online
like i went i went we were uh mark and i
did videos yeah yeah he's great we went
on and did multiplayer on i think some
star wars game and it we were so bad
it devolved into can you last four
seconds wow can and i would count up one
one thousand two
dead dead reap respawn one one thousand
and he got to four one time before
somebody goes well this thing you'll
you'll you know the average game is 35
40 minutes or something like that and
you'll die multiple
times but i turn off the chat and we
talked about it yeah yeah so i turn off
the allied chat and the enemy chat so no
one speaks to me no one can speak to me
but billy has it on i have
terrible
for even the bad guys even the enemy
everything yeah i hear what they're all
saying about me it's awful
in the league of legends community they
call that flaming when people flame you
they really do blame you but it doesn't
bother you
well no it does it does bother him it
does
turn it off yeah maybe i need to but he
doesn't he's not a very fast typer when
he's playing the game so i think
sometimes billy wants to like pause the
game and then type something kind of
sweet and switched on like you know why
would you be so cruel but you don't you
never have time so you're just like oh
you said something mean to me i'm always
like turn it off
it's not helping your game
but i will say and we know this the
average because you can go professional
with this game there are professional
gamers that do it for a living all that
kind of stuff
the average professional the the top 1
highest level players of league of
legends on the planet that do it for a
living win 50 of the time they win half
of their games yeah the other half they
lose so there's no shame in us losing
six games in a row which happens quite
often yeah but you've recently become
much
much improved i've got a little bit
better yeah people don't say his
horrible things anymore i've tested
their own levels and went through the
river
this must be massive yeah
if i'm playing against a computer and i
lose yeah i'm like fu buddy i have a
magic button and i go to settings easy
click and suddenly he's meet and back in
your boom
well yeah because there's there's a
difficulty setting yeah easy medium and
hard or whatever and i'm like i usually
play on medium but if i run into any
trouble i'm like
i've got a magic button
for life and what is that game what is
the game that you that you play more
often than not
uh they always change i like i like big
world games where you can explore and
also shoot people in the face
kind of like fine stuff fantasy or like
real stuff do you like like call of duty
or do you like like skyrim or world of
warcraft all of it because i like the
big world things as well yeah i like i
like the game starting
and the the basic next three or four
hours of the kind of gradual tutorial is
we're going to introduce you into a very
overwhelming world and we're going to
allow you to figure it all out for
yourself those are my favorite types
yeah far cry 6 i'm enjoying oh okay far
cry is great that series is great
because like you'll just be trying to do
something you'll be trying to get from a
to b to do your mission and suddenly
like a leopard will just come out of
nowhere and give you trouble or like
some rebels will be fighting the
government and then they get into your
way and you have to deal with that and
just like it's chaos and it's like i
can't and you like forget
why was i walking up the hill anyway i'm
just trying to survive at this point
yeah yeah i'm playing assassin's creed
odyssey right now or i was during the
last uh
job that i did and it's all based in
ancient greece and it a lot of
historical things so you're meeting
historical characters and being involved
in historical events where someone's
being
executed or there's a council or there's
a group of people teaching a certain
idea and these are things that actually
happened in ancient greek greece at that
time so there's a level of uh
of education going on at the same time i
love the big ones yeah i love assassin's
creed for that reason very cool and the
last time i think i saw you play a game
weren't you starting to wear the things
like virtually actually going in into
the game yeah are you still doing that
i i'm waiting for the graphics to get a
little better
i i think with once they come out with
the new virtual reality for the new
playstation there will be improved
they're going to have eye tracking for
it and everything and i think it's going
to be more immersive right now it's a
little
it's okay like uh for
for resident evil
7
they have they had uh not the most
recent resident evil called village but
the one before that they had a virtual
reality that was fabulous that's a
horror type vibe right i can't i can't
play horror games oh i don't know i do
not say that do you get scared well i do
get scared it's not necessarily that i
will play it because i because i get
scared which i might do yeah i just
unfortunately for me i i find it i find
it leaks into a slight sense of
negativity for me in some way my next
day i'm like
you know the world is a grimy dirty
place that's trying to attack me like
when i played gta 3
when i first came to la i played grand
theft auto 3 for months and what now
when i hear
a siren i don't think here comes the
police or an ambulance
i think i mean the game and also the
driving in the game it started to leak
into the way that i was driving around
the streets of la and i thought that's
probably not a good idea
the great thing that i love about about
league of legends is it's so bizarre and
it's so
outlandish the characters that you
played that you could never really think
it's real life it's such a fantasy right
yeah you got something weird on your
eyebrows but is that
just maybe the way it's growing what's
the word you like to say detritus is it
the truth do you have a little bit of
detritus well should we
oh we got a riddle should we do a riddle
now shall we
the first riddle and they're all from uh
john they're all from uh
is that from johnny clues yeah hey
johnny close that's our normal producer
he's not here okay we don't know where
he is no we don't he's not been here for
two weeks he's abandoned us but to be
fair i prefer mckenzie do you any girl
mckenzie all right first one
you see a boat filled with people it has
not sunk but when you look again you
don't see a single person on the boat
why
all right everyone just calm down for a
second well if the boat had sunk you
wouldn't see the ball either would you
good point
you see a boat filled with people
it is not sunk but when you look again
at the boat you don't see a single
person i've got it you've been struck
blind no i think i've got it go on
they're all married
yep there's no single person
thank you
thank you that is
[Laughter]
come on mackenzie give us number two
what english word has three consecutive
double letters
three considerable
[Laughter]
three consecutive double letters come on
james you're a man of the theater a man
of words
no doubt a shakespeare not a scholar
that's difficult mackenzie do you have
the answer there i do
and also she'd probably get it because
she's uh mckenzie grandma messianic do
you think would it be
would we get it very easily if he gave
us the first letter of giggle no no it's
three really your podcast is gonna make
me look stupid no no oh my god i've
gotta go call my publicist this is train
wreck
if she gives do you think that would be
fair first letter of the word is b
is b bubble no it's three
consecutive double letters
when one says three consecutive double
letters that is that just means that
the letters are double they're not like
b b c c d d no
consecutive doesn't even need to be in
the riddle well what does that so it's
not consecutive no it is it's
consecutive
no but that
so they're not right next to each other
it's not like b b u u they are but it
doesn't have to be like you know like
alphabetically like in order it but it's
two two two yeah
or anything in between them right one of
them might be a vowel yeah i think they
are right
so it's uh when do you get a double
vowel in a word well look i think the i
think the last of the double letters
i think the last of the double letters
is an s so it'd be something like
meaningfulness then you've got the two
s's at the end and then we're looking
for two before that i bet the last two
is an s and i think it's gonna be for
the vowel would make sense yes
bubbliness that's two we're just looking
but did it is the double letters right
next to each other
i will give you a hint it's not it does
not end with an s it doesn't happen i've
ruined it guys
here's a hint you could give us
what does the word mean
oh is that too much of an easy no
do we use it in normal english
vocabulary or would it be kind of a
unique word that you don't hear that
often
i wouldn't say
it's super unique that you wouldn't hear
it too often but delicious
it starts with the bee
and it and it's a way it's obviously a
way to just
it's a way to describe a person
a personality trait
it's a way to describe someone's job
a job a job brace job
why is it british i mean because she
said it was a british job
no i didn't job
it's a job that's done all over would
this job be done in australia
sure china
bulgaria
yes uh okay let me
without giving it away um
it's something that we probably
see every day that this person does
it starts with a b i'm just going to sit
in my kirk light so i appear in trouble
what english word has three consecutive
double letters and it's a way to
describe
a john one job someone's jump
meaning james don't you don't you
you're
are you still thinking you're looking
for your thoughts you're acting as if
it's tending more toward philosophy so
i'm not being helpful bob i don't i
think at this point i don't think we're
gonna get i think we will is the job in
some way
magical
if you are sure
if you open a book
book binder
now
open a
it has to do with that has to do with
reading what just as a hint what are the
first three syllables
has to do with reading
literally
it's someone's job yeah librarian but we
see it every day another another word
another word for a librarian see i don't
simply a bibliographer a biographer but
is it bibli does it start with bibli
that's only two syllables
that's allowable
i can give you another hand yeah so the
first um part of the word is book
book bookworm book bookish bookish
bookishness bookish
book
we're not very good at this one bookie
it ends
that was easy james james the master of
riddles one point for james one point
that means i have to get this otherwise
i'm gonna stab yourself it's a
disappointment yeah it is
they're on okay
one because we can't do a whole lower or
not
josh riddles all right a woman shoots
her husband then holds him under water
for five minutes next she hangs him
right after they enjoy a lovely dinner
explain she's a cannibal she said what
cannibal i thought she said the
cantaloupe no
she's a male a cannibal she shoots her
husband is she a cinematographer is she
is she a character
shoots her husband as in with a camera
does she shooting him on in a show in a
tv show
holds him underwater for five minutes oh
she's a photographer she shoots him with
a camera she gets she takes the film
puts it in the processing thing in the
water and she hangs him over the bath so
that he dries and right after they have
a lovely dinner
because they is that correct yep yeah
she took his picture and developed in a
in a dark room
one for you one for james well done we
been better absolutely
thank you thank you for the hint thank
you mackenzie grammer yeah
my candy grandma
that's never drama
with my cans and grandma
billy what growing up cereal was one of
my favorite parts of not only the
morning watching cartoons but also
coming home from school i would make
myself a nice big bowl of cereal some
milk in there and enjoy it now as a kid
i wasn't aware that a lot of sugar gets
hidden in cereal so it might not
necessarily be the most healthy thing to
eat as a kid or as a grown-up but i've
got a solution for you and it is
magic spoon cereal you tell me what's so
great about magic spoon i'm going to
give you some facts
magic spoon cereal
zero grams of sugar what's 13 to 14
grams of protein and only four neck
grams of carbs in each serving
only 140 calories a serving it's
keto-friendly gluten-free grain-free
soy-free and low-carb build your own box
available flavors to build your very own
custom bundle are cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter blueberry cinnamon cookies
and cream and maple waffle not only that
but because of the extreme popularity of
cookies and cream and maple waffle
flavor they've now made those
those flavors permanent when these
flavors were first introduced from town
they sold out so quickly that they
listened to the people eating the cereal
and they said right we're gonna bring
that back delicious i really like the
cookies and cream one it's it's super
duper tasty so go to magicspoon.com
to grab a custom bundle of cereal and
try it today and be sure to use the
promo code onion at checkout to save
five dollars off your order and magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's backed with a hundred percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked lovely remember
get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
slash onion and use the code onion to
save five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode guys are you struggling to
finish off your projects by the end of
the calendar year maybe your mind is
distracted with food that you're gonna
cook or christmas presents you need to
buy or where you're gonna go for new
year's well let me tell you if you need
a little bit of help with your
vocabulary oh yes your spelling maybe
where to put in an exclamation point
instead of a question mark you need to
use grammarly grammarly helps you
communicate clearly and kindly even when
you're in a hurry that's it tom
sometimes you're writing something and
you get into it and you and you go off
in tangents we go off in tangents
sometimes have you noticed that yeah
well if you do that grammarly will help
reel you back in or you can't find a
word
that'll help you or press that and
you'll find a synonym
maybe maybe you've said you want to say
the word happy but you don't want to say
the word happy very close to the the
fact that you've just said the word
happy so you ask gremlin and he says
well why don't you use the word
delighted exactly something like that
and if you're worried about what kind of
tone has this came across as what am i
being friendly am i being formal it's
got a tone detector so it will tell you
i tell you what that's a little bit too
formal for a letter to your grandmother
right i'll help you out with that tom
yeah striking a friendly tone for a
broad audience grammarly can help you
write it like you would normally say it
in a conversation like billy said also
you can help work on your confidence
grammarly turns i think we should keep
the logo small into let's keep the logo
small it's just a better way to use the
english language it's helping you tom so
take this stress out of the words right
away with grammarly our listeners get 20
off grammarly premium at grammarly.com
onion that's 20 off at
now james let's talk about your band a
little bit because billy's in a band too
goes to the robot
where are you guys at with that and how
did it come about
we are working on our fifth album wow uh
and the bassist kevin is finally letting
us know that he writes songs oh and he
is writing
incredibly good songs he might be
he might be he might be um yeah a new
one that he just uh gave us with san
francisco and it's just so beautiful
yeah we uh uh i was i was
i had been asked to play
uh clubs around los angeles
uh when i was doing buffy uh someone
asked me in an interview do you play any
musical instruments you know and i said
yeah guitar and i told them i used to
play in clubs when i was 13 years old
only playing james taylor i refuse to
play anything but james taylor
so that went out and somebody uh that
owned a club i think it was 14 below in
santa monica had the bright idea well if
we if we get this guy
if we book him it doesn't matter if he's
any good or not we'll sell a lot of
tickets because he's on television sure
enough i went and did it and i wasn't
very good
and we but we sold a lot of tickets and
so other clubs started asking me and
uh
my nadir was playing the key club which
is a big big club in uh in los angeles
and um and i wasn't very good and i knew
it and uh they came backstage and they
said pink is in the audience she can't
wait to she's a fan she can't wait to
hear you sing and i was like oh no this
is horrible she's good and sure enough
by the end of the show pink was nowhere
to be seen
for the exit
i wonder how long she lasted oh probably
i don't know like three bars i don't
know saucy pink
do you fancy here
yeah she's awesome i i've always been
quite attracted i liked a punky haircut
i find it amazing that she can sing
while she's up on like throwing around
on on cables and all that yeah
it's amazing isn't it so so you were
doing that as a solo show yeah so i
would try to get better and i would
rehearse and i had a microphone and i
had a you know and i had what my
neighbors were calling the karaoke
machine they hated me for this and i was
doing that and this 17 year old kid came
up to my door and said i'm hearing your
music
my name is charlie i just moved to town
and i have a band up in sacramento
called power animal we were getting
radio play up there and we cut an album
and i'm trying to sell it down here um
and we started talking and he gave me
one of his cds and i listened to it it
was just freaking amazing just
so surprising and so
um
i don't know singular uh it has singular
sound too yeah and um
and he he tried to shop the the album
and and
what do you know couldn't get in the
door uh and
uh we decided to uh we started talking
about what kind of songs we liked and we
started playing music for each other and
we decided to to start a band
and uh he said
if you have your own guys for the rhythm
section for drums and and bass you know
i'll be doing lead you can do rhythm
guitar but we need drums and bass i've
got two guys that were in power animal i
think they're really good uh if you have
your own guys of course but maybe want
to listen to you to my guys too and i
said sure why don't we have them out to
la what are they doing next weekend he
goes well
next weekend they're right now they're
in um new york playing jazz at lincoln
center but they'll be back in a week and
a half and i was like and how old are
they and he's like 16 and 17. i was like
yeah let's have him out yeah yeah let's
let's go meet these people and so uh i
met kevin and aaron uh and they were
just absolutely fabulous they just had
they had the combination of jazz which
which meant they could bubble
but they had the power of youth they
were just driving uh and within a month
we were cutting our first album and um
as soon as that was pressed we sorted
out to
to europe and
did a bunch of
two major european tours a lot of shows
all around the us and um
uh and we're still together and why
ghost of the robot what's that about um
i was concerned that
like i would i by that by this time i
was famous because of buffy and i was
concerned that i was gonna make money i
was going to get success and at the end
of the whole process i was going to end
up a douche bag
and at that point this whole experience
was going to be a bad thing in my life
if that happened so i was concerned
that i would become like the tin man
that that's that this success was
because i think that success is bad for
the human soul i think it tempts people
to think tempts me to think that i'm
different than other people that other
people can't understand my problems and
that i can't connect with people and
so i was i was concerned that i would be
like the tin man
in the wizard of oz yeah hollow on the
inside right and uh charlie was like ah
that's great i think of myself as a
robot
like an r2d2 this is a 17 year old right
it's like i'm i'm in the desert of
tantoween and i'm and i'm trying to get
over the rocks and i can barely get from
a to b on my wheels and then and then a
a woman will come along like a
pterodactyl swoop down and scoop me up
and take me up to the clouds and it's
amazing amazing then she drops me and i
fall to earth
bram crash and then i've got to figure
out how to get myself back up on my
wheels and continue my journey and so
the central idea and i was like robot
you know that's
that's a that's a nice image um
and
we came to ghost because that was kind
of like what i was afraid that i would
lose the inter the internal
you know so
we were talking about ghosts we're
talking about robot and at some point
the band uh i went over to one of their
houses and they were like we came up
with it it's robot ghost it's obvious
and i was like okay that's great
robot ghost is really good actually
but if you flip it around if you can go
ghost of the robot it's
rhythmically it's just kind of nice yeah
it's easier on the ear isn't it goes to
the robot instead of robot ghost yeah
it's a great name for a band yeah that's
a and
that that thinking that you had of
you know going through sort of fame and
at the end of it thinking oh actually
that was a
a bad thing did that come
do you think
because you you started off in theater
right yeah and you had your own theater
company like your actual theater [ __ ] you
were a producer yeah of a theater could
you talk a little bit about that so you
you were at
drama school in in new york
juilliard yeah so you did juilliard
tell us what happened when you left
there then well they kicked me out oh so
yeah they said i was no good at acting
and i should quit before i got at what
point in your training was that they
they cut half the class at two years
right
that's what they did well they don't do
that anymore because it was really
really cruel
yeah yeah but they did it back then did
you still pay for the full thing or did
they give you half your money back i
didn't pay for it that was not scholarly
i mean in general when that used to
happen would they give you half your
money back when they kick you out
halfway through no i think cause you
just pay year to year you know one bit
at a time um so
yeah i was uh that's painful that's
awful it's horrible as an actor that's
just like
i mean we're used to being rejected in
terms of you didn't get the job you
didn't get you know you didn't get that
they gave the job to someone else but
not
we will not allow you to train to be an
actor anymore that's
that is
especially from an acting school who
knows how painful that is yeah yeah yeah
that is wow but that's really the fire
in my belly
the old
you know i did it oh yeah but it could
have went the other way yeah yeah easy
and i'm sure it does for him
yeah and well it convinces a lot of
people that it's not a fun thing to do
when the fact it really is it's just
yeah it's not fun to get the job but the
job is actually really fun well we all
have to get used to rejection in our
being whatever successful actors we all
have to be very good with rejection
because a huge amount of job is rich
yeah and you know what helped me with
that was having a theater company was
doing casting right uh because we would
we would have mammoth casting sessions
because we couldn't pay a lot of money
so we knew that we we were going to be
trying to find the young actors that
were destined to go on and be fully
professional but we had to grab those
people out of the sea of people around
them and find them so we would we
once a month we would spend the whole
weekend
auditioning people right and of course
when you're casting a specific play you
have to go through the auditions for
that as well and you just you just
realize there's so much more than
just how good of a person they are or
how beautiful they are or how any of the
things that i would
assume was the reason i didn't get a
role might not be it at all
it might just be the height
of
you know stacking up you know with the
other cast or this might be how the
might be a million things yeah uh and
that that really helped me i remember
when i came down to los angeles i was
like you know what someone's looking for
me today right now yeah they woke up
this morning hoping to meet me although
they've never met me they've got in
their mind they want specifically me and
we're probably not going to meet each
other right but if i can keep going out
and meeting people yeah sometimes at
some point
i'm going to meet that person because
it's a big town yeah someone's looking
at form for me all the time yeah i've
just got to keep out there until we meet
i remember having an audition where i
walked through the door
i've told you the story before
and the lady looked up as i walked
through the door they looked up and went
no
and i just went
oh
and as i turned around there's a there
was a height thing on the ah
it was like six one or six way up
dom knows this story when i when i uh
started drama school because i went to
drama school in scotland
and uh the head of the school came in to
give the the actors of that year
their the talk for entering the school
you know and they did that thing of them
you know if anyone here feels like they
can do anything else
please go and do it
he says because an actor is it's a
different art he says if you're a
painter
people will say i hate that painting if
you're a poet or hate the poem but if
you're an actor they hate you
and he says and that is a painful thing
to go through your life you know
and then you know and there's something
in your story of juliet i can't believe
they they would do that i didn't know
that not just about you but about
historically they would get rid of half
the class and say you shouldn't be here
well they they took a special umbrage to
me
yeah because at one point
i was
i was in a it was our first play of the
first year and it was the um
they called it the discovery play and we
were doing troilus cressida which is a
not one of shakespeare's best yes and uh
it was horrible it was being directed by
one of the best broadway actors ever
marion zelde's just luminous right and
as good as she is as an actor that's how
bad she is
oh she's dead now so it's hard to see
god rest herself sorry man you know it's
true so um
so
we were i had come from a two-year
program in southern california that was
very very good that was apprenticeship
where you just watched really good
actors go from first rehearsal to final
performance directors were some of the
finest on the west coast it was really a
good experience right and i was not used
to being in bad place or just
unspeakably horrible
and marion just kept saying oh my birds
keep exploring keep exploring you go you
go and the thing is just unwatchable and
we're three days away from an audience
and i'm like
i'm a juilliard and this is horrible
there's got to be a reason for this
there's something that i need to figure
out yeah why is it called the discovery
play and i started asking around and no
one could tell me why it was called this
and i said okay i got that's the test we
got to figure out yeah what are we
supposed to discover and then i thought
maybe it's not our discovery maybe it's
the school's discovery of the kind of
the kind of class that we are if we're
left to our own devices are we just are
we going to tell a story or are we just
going to
right yeah yeah um if no one gives us
help and i said well this kind of this
class has me
so i stood up and i said guys this is
unbearably boring this is horrible the
kind of stuff we're doing is great for
the first week of rehearsal but we've
got to make choices we've got to tell a
story because people are going to come
and share a piece of their life with us
that they'll never get back and on some
level they'll never forgive us if we
waste that time
yeah so let's make some choice let's
block the play please you know and that
just let that just
there i apparently was wrong
that wasn't the discovery we're supposed
to make it was just that that marion was
a bad director and they thought i was
just you know this this upstart young
actor that knew better than everybody
right and they labeled me as a as a jerk
and they troubled
me for two years until they kicked me
out oh great
and and and then what so you're in your
shop
anymore
i'm trying to by the time i get out of
juilliard it's it's in the mid 80s and
um
uh the property rates had gone so far up
in manhattan that all of the entry-level
theaters had closed down all off
off off-broadway all that stuff was gone
right
and
just trying to to break into the larger
houses that no one wanted to see me um
and so i was just bartending and my
girlfriend at the time who later became
my wife and producing partners she came
and said i am going to chicago that's
where it's all at right now it's not
happening theater's not really happening
in new york right now but it's bubbling
in chicago so i'm going if you want to
come with me that's fine if you don't
see you later so i followed the woman
out to chicago and found a city that was
absolutely on fire you could not you
couldn't walk 10 blocks in chicago
without some little theater some play
happening in some little storefront
somewhere it was just electric and
that's where you started your company
yeah did you find the space and then
just thought i'm going to do it or did
you rent spacesuits rent it okay rent it
it was when we we but by our we only did
two shows in chicago but the second one
was a hit and at that point we thought
okay we need a permanent space and we
need to get a board of directors we need
to plant roots and the question was do
we do we want to die in chicago and it
gets cold in chicago windy city oh my
god and so uh it was also happening in
seattle uh that was bubbling up there
were plays coming out of seattle and
they were being produced elsewhere and
that seemed like another center at the
time it was in the
early 90s i guess and uh
moved out to seattle and that's when we
got a permanent space and that's when we
kind of like we started churning out
plays once a month
have you been have you been to seattle
yeah yes amazing coffee but starbucks
well that is where starbucks is from
right i also thought that
alongside
is it portland oregon that also has like
a crazy crazy coffee scene but the whole
area seattle i remember being in seattle
thinking man i wonder if billy's been
there because the coffee
was just amazing yeah i love coffee cafe
culture it was it was it was it had a
cafe culture before starbucks really
took off around other places but it was
like paris
and seattle do you still do theater do
you ever do see on that i
no because i mean like i i i
i'm thinking of doing this again there's
a um la theater works
is a great thing uh here in la where you
rehearse for like four days
and then you read the play in front of a
live audience you have four performances
and then that is recorded and put out on
npr brilliant yeah
and so i've done a lot of plays with
them um and i haven't done that for a
while yeah but basically you do a play
and they ask for three months
of your life and i've got kids in
college and theater doesn't pay i mean
the whole reason i came down here was to
get them through college and i told my
kids like you get the grades i'll find
the money okay go
and they have taken me up on this and
now my daughter is pursuing a doctorate
in mathematics and my son's in law
school so they're just like oh you'll
pay for hmm well i'll get the grades no
problem so they have they're doing
everything i hope for but it means that
for a few more years anyway you've got
to make money and i have this dream that
i will go back to theater for sure
running radio play
ever
oh
no
do you want to introduce well we i said
to james about the eat the world thing
and he sent a very a very nice note back
to me that made me laugh quite heavily
so uh
sure do you want to introduce it or
shall i read the note oh read the note
that's fine
yeah yeah um we're all underneath
whatever yeah so as i said i said to
james you know
me and dom do this um eat the world
segment and uh we'd like you to bring
we'll we like people who talk about food
that maybe they had growing up or
neighborhood or or you know something
from the country that they come from
something that reminds them of um of uh
growing up and you said that sounds like
fun
my mother god dressed their soul can i
read all of this as well
yeah yeah
my mother god dressed her soul was a
terrible cook
just
inexplicably horrible
maybe she had a medical condition
stunted taste buds shrivel palette lord
only knows point is i have memory of
boiled lima beans
that are so bad as to be emotionally
scarring
so if you guys could take cheap frozen
lima beans boil them up so they're very
dry like desiccated sell them without
salt or butter seeing your faces eat
them might heal my blackened heart
that's what we've got so we thought that
was fantastic and we've got mackenzie to
cook up some lovely lovely lima beans
now is it lemur or limer would you say
lemon i would say lima but i wouldn't
say it because well you haven't been
you've been
okay lima beans great now so
when your mum would make this would this
be a side dish would it come with some
chicken and and some other vegetables or
would it just be yeah a bowl of no that
would be the vegetable of the day you
know
so this would be dried pork chop there
or like
chicken livers she loved that
my dad likes chicken livers barbecued
chicken here comes sleeper
oh he's brought napkins this
come on i think that's a few wretch
right okay i'm a fan of beans
oh okay
i am messy i'm good oh really now if you
don't gag i'm going to claim that
mackenzie is a better cook than my mom
that's what i'm going to say no we
haven't unless you go in me no we have
you like a beanie like a bean
what is it a legume yeah lagoon i like a
butter beet like my dad i like a butter
bean a hariko bean i like a a similar to
a butter bean okay i'm okay with it but
oh no no no do you want to shelve yours
yeah yeah
so we've said
mckenzie make them exactly as james
remembers them with nothing no no no so
talk before we before we try james just
talk us through the preparation
what we i don't know how she did it
because as i said i was a kid
and you know very quickly what she was
cunning at was though she we immediately
wanted to cook food she did not have to
get us to learn how to cook we couldn't
wait until we were allowed to cook our
own food because we were just horrified
about we were having to eat she would
set a timer she would service stuff like
this and she would set a timer that we
had to finish the food it was
yeah so
so here we are she just did and this is
why you found it quite easy and i
haven't vampiric
then because food is horrible you
haven't eaten them since do you have
another fish i have not really not
so we're going to give
them a go
oh yeah do you remember that good job
good job mackenzie
i mean they very quickly do desiccate in
your mouth that's it yeah it does uh it
just sucks all the moisture out
yeah stringing and um yeah and we'd have
about that much and you'd have to you'd
have to finish them
dude
and there'd be like a pork chop
oh some dried out piece of meat nothing
green did your mum serve them because
she'd read an article saying that
lima beans were really healthy or that
they were good for you
did she like them
would she wolf them down and be like
what are you doing they're fantastic i
was just i was i was consumed by my own
misery and self-pity and i wasn't
noticing her reaction to the lima beans
at all i was just feeling sorry for
myself these are really horrible i mean
i mean it's it's completely dull bland
yeah and gritty kind of neat
honestly i don't think they're
unpleasant really they're just boring
they're just god
but if you had them every week oh every
week you know so see this and i'm why am
i having another had one yeah don't put
yourself through too much i actually
quite like
them when i started playing in a band
yeah that's this guy billy johnson that
i played in the band with bj bj i would
go up to his house and we'd play guitar
together you know and and dream about
being in a rock band and i remember his
mum
um would bring his dinner in
to his room while we were playing and he
used to open the window of his bedroom
and just scrape the dinner he lived two
up
so it just didn't in the backyard
wow it was that bad
well i don't know i've mentioned it to
him but he's never really kind of told
me the whole story he wouldn't but not
the whole lot but i think he probably
didn't like his mum to know that he'd
left some what do you remember him
scraping off baked beans and i can't
even remember did she bring any food for
you or it was just a subtle kind of
message i think there's a short message
you shouldn't be here
[Laughter]
food now i used to love food i so do so
i wonder why i didn't eat it rather than
him maybe that's why it's stuck in my
head i got interested in magic because
the trick was to get this kind of stuff
into your lap like get you get a napkin
on your lap and pretend to eat it and
then get a little bit on your oh she
wasn't looking so you could like
put it in your pants and get rid of it
later and i remember just thinking
magicians have it made they can they can
get that done oh my parents laugh at me
now and we've all laughed at it when i
when i became an adult where they would
because i was a very fussy eater as a
kid and they said we we would watch you
as a kid
and then go
i've got a toilet
yeah you can go to the toilet you've got
something in your mouth
and then i'll come back and be like okay
great and then two minutes later i do
the same thing and they said we would
just sit there at dinner and just laugh
at you thinking that you were pulling
the wall over our eyes or like hiding
stuff in the side of a chair and stuff
like that yeah
he cooked dinner
and you
you hated it so much that you ordered
the pizza yeah and you didn't know and
stuck it in your spare room
and then while you guys were at dinner
you just snip off to this bear room and
have a slice of pizza is that true it's
true so this is i love it now but at the
time
i had a strong aversion to broccoli
and my brother made like a broccoli bake
which is basically like oven baked
broccoli with a bit of cheese and maybe
some breadcrumbs and something and he
thought it was the bee's knees and at
the time i love broccoli now at the time
it was my least favorite vegetable yeah
so he made a big deal i was at work all
day and i came home and he said don't
worry about dinner made you this big
broccoli bake and i was like
i'm not gonna eat it so i secretly
ordered a pizza when it showed up
big pizza i hid it in my spare room and
then yeah i love it you're kind-hearted
enough to to hide the pizza well also i
didn't want to get teased because i knew
that my brother if he found out that i
wasn't eating the um
the broccoli bacon give me a hard time
because he always used to he used to
call me a little bird when i was kidding
he was like well you
you eat your food like a little baby
bird like picking at something which is
true i'm quite picky i have to say james
i'm still eating these okay but the
truth is i think it's your memory no no
this is also true this is also true a
child has four times the amount of taste
buds as an adult
yeah but our taste buds die off as we
enter into adulthood so we don't know
the pain that we're putting kids through
right when they say oh this is horrible
it's because they're tasting something
that we can't right that's why we we get
more accustomed to spicy food as we get
older and stuff like that you want to
read a little blurb is it limer or lima
adays i
limer i would say
mackenzie has been kind enough to also
cook some lima beans
uh with some um
actual flavor in it have you garlic and
salt yeah so we've got some garlic salt
see
so maybe you could have a taste we could
change your whole maybe i will
that would
and then you just absolutely love it and
let me see if you ended up loving it
james okay then the 20th of no chance
april every year
20th of april you would love it because
that's national
lima bean respect
did you know that it has a day
everything has a day these days doesn't
it well to get a little serious for a
second although you know not crazy
serious but just to you know
be frank about it today is world aids
day oh well yeah
it's world aids day as a way of you know
remembering yeah well that's great that
deserves a day
really at some point there'll be a
national covert day is it like it comes
i think it's lime here comes mckenzie
grammar oh we'll scoop a bit on top
that's a good idea hold on
oh yes let's see it's got some flavor
now james i think you're going to love
this all right kenzie lovely i feel like
we're having thanksgiving together
mackenzie oh do you want some gravy with
that you're right thank you mackenzie
greaves now that's got a nice smell no
it's got a smell is this with garlic
salt or with garlic yes
she chopped the garlic fresh so it's
fresh mackenzie you're gonna make
someone a fantastic wife one day
it is substantially less horrible yeah
it is almost completely edible
that's not okay next stop
i would see
minutes ruined by the lima bean it's a
lot of garlic
not enough
and i'll tell you what to save a lima
bean if there's one thing that a vampire
doesn't love
it's garlic right yeah why is that
that's true yeah
let's test your knowledge of vampires
why do they hate garlic i mean
understand the cross thing and the holy
water well they're
most of them you know come from old time
england and they had very boring food
right
and the italians they were all like oh
i'm not like an italian no i don't eat
garlic
and so they look down on garlic
so it's basically a racist kind of thing
right
cultural thing
i wonder if bram stoker did not like
garlic you know in israel was bram
is brem
stoker's real name abraham and he just
shortened it to bram or is he known as
bram do you know bills
and was stoker um shortened from
struck a defense stuckerson
weren't you reading frankenstein when we
were doing
i love frankenstein michelle yeah it's a
great great book first sci-fi book
interesting very first one
brilliant yeah it's an amazing book
no one sends me a book sent you a bit
frankenstein well you know there could
you should open that japanese gift well
i mean absolutely lovely that mckenzie
well done
that's delicious should we give him some
scores killed me i don't mind these
things
we could give you some facts about lima
beans but you know i mean it's a bean
what what can we say
we can see um in the u.s it is a warm
season crop grown mainly in delaware and
the mid-atlantic region
for processing in the midwest in
california for dry beans baby lima beans
are planted nearly june and harvested
about 10 or 12 weeks later in western
new york state baby lima bean production
increased exponentially from
what exponentially
from 2011 to 2015.
james is that in thinking that delaware
is the smallest american state rhode
island i think oh yeah what is there's
something about
something about delaware i mean
obviously there's something about every
state that's unique but there's
something about delaware that's stuck in
my the president is from delaware
joe biden yeah scranton yeah
where if my hand yeah was the the united
states of america yeah
california yeah new york new mexico is
down here yeah
where is delba
well it's the finger that we can't
really put out in place
right right very little bit not right at
the end but but probably right there
right that wrinkle right around there
okay above new york
but i think so is that above or below i
don't know well that's below isn't it
because then your index finger kind of
the the the oh i'm saying there's so
many states over there they're just it's
their own massive amount of state can't
keep them you know i'm from the west
coast we got california arizona colorado
i know where all that stuff is done
right
easy but you get in you get in there and
it's jesus kentucky's easy to remember
because you just draw a chef holding a a
a tray yeah pan and then it's a chicken
in it yeah actually chicken took a fried
chicken yeah and isn't there something
slightly confusing about
midwestern states isn't the midwest
mid-east isn't it in the east the
midwest do you know what i mean like
it's well
because when when when those states were
put on that was the west ah
who's the two guys that went across
um uh oh with uh uh
like the americans just said you two
guys don't find out what happens if you
go west stubs and no stubs oh you're
thinking of thunder and hooch no that's
something else that's tom hanks yeah
oh you should know this james i really
should isn't it
i'll tell you who'd know this oh my god
mackenzie grandma
[Laughter]
who's the two guys that the americans
can we be honest but nothing against the
lima bean uh industry which i know i
don't want you to get you know hate mail
on that but it is the worst beef is it
come on you like butter beans love a bug
is a butter bean more or less edible
butter bean is better than this bean so
it was a
i thought that was a butter bean no no
no no no no butter bean would be buttery
as opposed to chalky yeah that's the
same shape though isn't it yes it is
that this is a
lesser
you know bean really things now here's
something about butter beans
that uh johnny clues just told us
um hold on kidney bean awesome like
being wonderful kidney bean but you have
to be careful with the bronzer bean not
bad correctly it'll kill you garbanzo
beans why the term butter bean is widely
used in north and south carolina for a
large flat and yellowy white variety of
lima bean
in the united states siever type beans
are traditionally called butter beans
also otherwise known as the dixie or
henderson type in that area
lima beans and butter beans are seen as
two distinct types of beans are you from
that area
although they are the same species
in the united kingdom and the united
states butter beans refers to either
dried beans which can be purchased to
rehydrate or the canned variety which
are ready to use in culinary use lima
beans and butter beans are distinct well
done james you're absolutely right
the former being small and green the
latter large and yellow
in areas where both are considered to be
lima beans the green variety may be
called as baby and less commonly
junior
i have i know that i am i am prejudiced
against lima beans i know that i have a
distorted view of them i accept that
however i've never been to a very very
wonderful restaurant and been served
them no i haven't but i was going to
tell you
but i was going to tell you a story
there about butter beans i remember
being in a restaurant with my father
austin hello hi austin and he ordered
for his starter a
butter bean soup and it was beautiful
like really creamy and it had full
massive butter beans they were like this
big in them and he loved it and he gave
us all the taste and i thought they were
fantastic i agree with you james these
are like a drier chalkier cheaper
version of a butter bean but i don't
dislike them maybe they grow in soil
that has problems with other bees i
don't know i quite like them let's give
them some
balance very generally we now score and
there is three categories to the scoring
one
test okay two
aesthetics aesthetics how does it look
three
usefulness how useful is this food i
don't get demonstrated that one
yeah
everyone goes what i mean if you had it
in your fridge what could you do with it
well let's start let's start with flavor
okay let's not start with james no never
because we know it's going to be
rejected
we can't go off of of of the good one
listen you've just got to go the plane
lima we're going with a plain one listen
i agree they're a bit drier than you'd
want and as it's as we've got them in
this form which is the form that you
grew up with
they're not that pleasant i would say
these in a slightly spicier tomato soup
or sauce would be quite palatable but in
this dried form as the year as they are
i'm going to give them a six i think
they're all right
and in the dry form as you've given us
them
as you would have got them from your
mother yeah
i would have to give them a
4.5
yeah you can break up the number if you
want into a decimal yeah we go decimals
but only one point
james what's the lowest flavor
nothing has ever got zero has it nothing
nothing zero
unshame
yeah it just just you can't even
indefensibly bad well that's a that's
our first zero day right now aesthetics
how does it look looks fine to me i mean
i mean it looks like a zombie version of
another
i'm going to say it's it's quite a
beautiful it's almost expensive not
actually quite like i feel as if see if
i found that on the beach i'd put it on
a necklace and i'd say to people i found
this on the beach in in mexico
and it says it's a lima bean i say is it
yeah
so i'm going i'm going to say that's
beautiful and give it an 8.7 okay i mean
in terms of how nature has fashioned and
shaped
the bean and they're all relatively
uniform i quite like them as well i
think it's a beautiful shape so i'm
i'm going to give it a 7.5
i'll go ahead and give it a four okay no
no you're infecting me with generosity
yeah because there's a certain joy to
the being also i want to be fair yeah
good so that my zero means something
we're getting you through this james
this is a little bit thin i'm about to
cry yeah you just want this no i think
we've really hit the nail on the head
here bean soup
delicious as you've mentioned as austin
had in a curry
i don't know if i'd put it in a curry
wouldn't you like a chilli maybe chili
in a chili and a ch and a pie
bean pie yeah you mental yes
um
all right
puff pastry okay are you mad all right
all right nice mustard coleman you can
do a bean ice cream of course you could
do a bean ice cream wouldn't be very
nice
[Laughter]
bean bean juice bean juice are you
sticking the juice
see that drop it could actually maybe
cure cholesterol change the world maybe
but when i think of usefulness i think
of what can this bean do that another
bean can't and then on that metric i
have to again give it a very lo i can't
think of anything that i would prefer i
would prefer to make a soup with
buttercream okay okay i would or a chili
i would like to use a different bean
so what you're saying what's that good
for you in comparison to other beans
it's probably your least favorite
absolutely and probably the least useful
bean of all beans i think so in its raw
form you could
try to play tiddlywinks with it you
could do you know that tiddlywink yeah
you could probably flick it i don't wear
a wink
or uh marbles you could
you could head it with your thumb
usefulness in terms of its adaptability
into other dishes and and the fact that
it can be made in other dishes
i'm gonna give it up
i'm gonna give it an eight i'm gonna
give that an eight point two
you just try i just tried to
is absolutely flavorless it is it is
therefore you can you can use it as
filler in many ways so i can see
some usefulness to
i'm it have to go with a three point
seven five minutes low i think that
number i think before we started that
would have been like a 1.2 yeah yeah so
i think we've upped
your your thought about this been yeah
well it's a slow process healing does
not come overnight no it doesn't come
overnight well i've got stuff on my
especially childhood drugs and how often
do you think you got these beans
once a week once a week
hey oh hey james this is great we're
loving it love the chat i'm loving it
right this is fantastic
we'll continue this next week on the
friendship onion i would love to hear
more you got it so um but don't forget
everybody to uh what is that again like
yeah it's rate review and subscribe
because if you give us
a nice review and if you give us uh a
nice kind of set of stars and stuff it
allows us to do more shows
and that's what we want to do we want to
keep making the show down keep eating
lemonade also send all your emails to us
at the friendship on your
netcastmedia.com that's cats with a k or
you can leave a voicemail at
speakpipe.com forward slash the
friendship onion and we will see you
with us and james next week on the
friendship onion bye thanks james
[Music]